[Music]
hey everybody time once again for
another matinee on which we talk about
new movies now this one is one that just
dropped on shudder came out in 2020 I
don't know like a great deal about where
it came from or where it premiered or
anything like that um this one is called
confessional now this I'm gonna say like
right from the outset this is gonna be
like a divisive movie because I don't
know if I would call it a horror movie
per se I'm gonna call it an experimental
mystery type thing and it's and it's got
like a very theatrical sort of vibe it's
almost kind of like a stage play I think
in the way that it is it's where the
script came from maybe um now the woman
that wrote this is her first full-length
feature Jennifer wolf the guy that
directed it Brad got Fred was this is
third movie I think so I'm gonna say
that if you're not into like
experimental [ __ ] movies or if you like
more like traditional type of horror
movies then you will probably hate this
but I actually found myself like really
engrossed in it like I said it's kind of
a mystery story I've seen it compared to
the Netflix series thirteen reasons why
I also got kind of like an Agatha
Christie kind of vibe or you know
something like that where it's mostly
it's very dialog heavy and it pretty
much all takes place in one very small
like location in this case like a
soundproof booth you know it cuts back
and forth to you know a few other
locations like an flashback and things
like that but not very often
so pretty much the whole movie is just
like various characters talking to the
camera in like a confessional booth and
like as their conversations go on you
learn more and more about the situation
at hand because what the whole premise
of the movie is is that this is said it
an unnamed College I believe it's
unnamed and there have been two very
high-profile deaths on campus one of
them is a girl named Amelia who is a
videographer and she was working on a
you know kind of a video project of
doing like confessionals so she has all
these she has all this dirt on people
like she has all these people talking
about their deepest secrets and
everything like that she ended up dying
from a drug overdose even though she
never done drugs
anything and that was ruled a suicide
and then there was another student named
Zach who was like a you know it's like a
champion swimmer and he had died in a
swimming pool he had drowned in a
swimming pool and he also had drugs in
his system and that was ruled an
accident and then it seems like there
were six people I think it was six
people who were friends you know lovers
acquaintances whatever of these two
people in varying capacities and an
unknown person has drawn them all to
this confession booth you know
threatening them with blackmail because
of all of the stuff that Amelia like all
the dirt that Amelia had on them and is
like you have to come here and confess
what you know about these two people's
deaths or I will release all this
information and you don't find out who
is behind all of this until the end so
this is almost kind of like a meta
film-within-a-film because they kind of
portray it as a film project but then
it's actually a movie as well you know
what I'm saying so far Jenny's pretty
much knocked it out of the park this is
a great description of the movie yeah
and I would say you know just based on
this description if you're a regular
listener you guys wouldn't know that I
couldn't stand this movie yeah I
couldn't stand very dialogue heavy well
it's pretty much all dialogue there are
no I mean and I'm gonna say right now if
that sounds like something you would
hate they don't watch it because it's
you know you're not gonna like it look
coming from the theatre you know I mean
I have a upbringing early on in a
theatre this had to this screenplay was
it was a play yeah this is something
that you did live and live I think this
would have been really good yeah what
works live on a stage man is the second
you know very different from what works
in film in cinema the mom you want a
bunch of different locations you want
action you want you know what I mean you
want to see stuff happen and that
doesn't really happen in this movie
because cuz of the constraints of the
screenplay I mean there can be great
movies all set in one location at once I
mean look at Alfred Hitchcock's for
example but you guys got a look at it
that was another eros yeah churros
people came from a background of [ __ ]
vaudeville and lie
performance so those audiences are a lot
more tolerant to that kind of
storytelling yeah
nowadays this [ __ ] doesn't fly yeah I
mean unless it's a kind of a person
that's into this yeah there is a certain
job you know like this movie will make
money
I don't probably make more it's more
than its budget back yeah you know and
because it's it's you know it's a
low-budget movie
I mean it's nicely shot that maybe
she'll like it really is it doesn't look
cheap in this guy good acting the acting
in it and really the acting in it
because a lot of the people I've met
have been in some big stuff a couple of
them in been in Dexter one was on
Criminal Minds like Alyssa so these
aren't like nobodies yeah and um you
know for the most part like this isn't
really an actor's movie in the sense
that pretty much the whole entire time
yes all they're doing is looking at the
camera and talking and having to like a
moat and expression both express
emotions and things of that nature so I
think they all do a really really good
job
doing that if you're if you know if
you're into this kind of stuff then you
might like it if your average Joe a
McDonald's style [ __ ] film watcher
you know what I mean you're not gonna
like a movie most likely yeah and I you
know and I do and I do want to say that
if you're very into just a standard like
horror movie or even a standard thriller
or mysteries and any cool movies with us
what you want where then you will not
like this at all because this is
basically like watching it's an artsy
movie yeah it's basically like watching
a theatrical performance because it's
all pretty much all in this booth and
it's all it cuts back and forth between
these various people and like various
revelations like come out slowly as each
of them talks and you know what I mean
and then like later on there's a mystery
about who's like engineer all of this
and stuff yeah if I were watching it you
know live a lot yeah it's in a theatre
you don't I mean it would have had a
totally different it gave me that
impression now and I will say that you
know you know as anybody that watches
this regularly knows I'm like a lot more
tolerant of you know I don't like
everything but I'm a lot more tolerant
of different types of film styles so I'm
just kind of like I kind of really got
into because at first I was hesitant and
I was just like a man is the whole movie
gonna be like this but then as everybody
started talking and as
more like details about the story about
the deaths and stuff started to come out
and how like everybody related to each
other and stuff I kind of got more into
it so I got like really invested in what
was going on in everyone's story but
this is something where you really have
to listen to everybody's dialogue and
the connections between everybody and
stuff like that to really get the most
out of it so this is one that you really
need to like give your full attention
yeah and I'm almost kind of the opposite
I think as I get older and as time goes
on I've become less tolerant of movies I
actually personally believe it's a dying
shun rrah
a lot of genres of art have died like
you know you don't hear people do epic
poems anymore you know you know you know
I you know people aren't really paying
to go and see people recite poetry
anymore you know eventually movies will
go that way I think really what's
replaced him has been videogames well
yeah all right because it's been
interact it's interactive and in the
future movies will be something damn
that's kind of virtual reality you'll
feel like you're there you do there is a
story and maybe you have some input in
the story
maybe there's a damn AI computer [ __ ]
you know taking readings off your brain
and [ __ ] computing what would be the
most optimal story for this particular
person so everybody experiencing the
movie has a slightly different story
because well you can see how they're
really trying to do like really
rudimentary stuff with that like black
mirror tried to do with Bandersnatch
like where it's kind of like a
choose-your-own-adventure right like you
know as you were watching it you can
make decisions for the characters and
then the story would go a different way
yeah um so I can see things go here
that's or here's a whole generation of
kids growing up on interactive video
games [ __ ] they want to hear
somebody else's story yeah they want to
make there they want to make their own
story which in a way is kind of cool you
know yeah but there are classics you
know what I mean like I'll go back to
[ __ ] carpenter you know the thing you
know carpenters version of the thing
that's something that everybody should
see you know I believe the same thing
with like Escape from New York the very
first one there's all kinds of classic
movies
but every art form kind of has a [ __ ]
half-life if you ask me you know a man
in the film is I think it's days are
numbered it'll eventually be like
something you stream on demand they'll
be good ones there'll be a lot of bad
ones you know like Marvel they made some
good ones they made a lot of money with
that also i-i've just as I've gotten
over I've become less artistic I think
that's a shame yeah well I'm looking I
look at I look at movies is more like a
vehicle to make money even though I'm
not involved in the money making process
I'm watching it thinking I wouldn't have
invested in this movie I'd be losing my
ass right about now as I was I think
that way now you know I mean like or I
see a movie go this movie kind of sucks
but the but they would buy that they'll
buy the hell out of this movie you know
I can tell you know I don't see I don't
like I guess because I'm an artist
myself so I don't like approach things
that way necessarily I mean like like I
can tell like if I see a movie and it's
like really blatant kind of cash-grab or
something like that then I'm probably
not gonna like it I mean and I was
talking to somebody a little bit about
in the YouTube comments because we were
talking about we just shark and how um
you know he was saying that he really
liked like these kind of just low-budget
yeah I couldn't Christ and I was like I
like him too and it's like well the
thing about it is that if you can tell
they're not really trying to make money
necessarily it's just they want I mean
maybe they are but maybe that was like a
secondary consider they just wanted to
have a good time they wanted to make a
funny movie they wanted people to see it
obviously but um you know I think that
comes across when even if you do want to
make money on it it comes across if like
it's something that you really wanted to
make or you had a good time making or
you enthusiastic well I can different I
can differentiate a tentpole movie has
to [ __ ] involves a lot of money it
has to sell to a wide range of people
that's got to be McDonald's yeah that
just has to please everybody write a
[ __ ] low-budget movie to make that
good it's gotta be it's gotta be
something gourmet it's got to be
targeted to a particular particular
audience and when in a situation like
that you don't want too many cooks in
the kitchen
you want the movie to be the vision of
maybe one or two guys yeah and that's it
that's kind of what I want and I like
this I do like those like weed shark I
was entertained yeah because I could
tell
it was the vision of maybe one or two
guys they were [ __ ] with me they're
trolling me through the movie I'm
laughing in there laughing well yeah
they just wanted to make their nothing
balls obviously analyzing is serious
yeah and that's that's totally fine yes
it's totally fun as long as we got like
some entertainment value out of it then
I'm actually good I'm actually more apt
to enjoy a dumbass movie like that then
to something that's into Watson is
really like high-minded and artistic
yeah I mean and this movie I think is
very artistic I don't think it makes
very good cinema I think it'd be a much
better stage play
I would I would actually be curious to
see a live version of them yeah although
like I said I think the more that I
watched it the more I kind of forgot
that it was like a movie if that makes
sense like because it because it gave me
like a very theatrical sort of vibe like
it in the sense of live theatre for me
in movies by motion and about [ __ ]
visuality and visual style a good
example would be like the John wick
movies I [ __ ] love them
yeah there's a lot of action a lot color
it is very artistic there was very
tasteful color palettes just the the
effects that they did like somebody
thinks something or says something and
words have come up or just [ __ ] like
that you know I mean I thought that was
that's really how you do an action movie
to me that's perfect cinema
yeah you're sitting there you're going
on a ride and you're watching it you're
invested in the characters and you're
going places with the character so
that's what I like yeah and you don't
have a sit really a sense of going
anywhere with these people um you're in
one place the whole time which that
works on on stage yeah yeah you know
what this reminded me a little bit of
and I think I don't know if we ever
reviewed it formally but I think I
talked about it maybe on one of the side
tracks or like a long time ago on
Halloween when I was recommending a
bunch of movies this reminded me a
little bit of that movie circle where
everybody was trapped in that one room
and like they had to like vote on who
was gonna get electrocuted or killed or
whatever so it's very much almost like
the platform or something like that that
we reviewed a while back where it's kind
of like you know just a aged kind of
like enclosed area and you know it's
almost kind of like a really
you know not I can't think of the word
that I want to use but um it's just kind
of like this really you know enclosed
kind of thing where everything happens
in this one place you know what I mean
the contrived that's the word that I was
looking for a very contrived like
situation so that's a little bit what
this one was like because it was almost
kind of like meta in the sense that it
was like an art installation like inside
a movie inside it might be kind of thing
so like I said if that sounds like
something you would dig I'm not gonna
recommend it to everybody but you know
if you like that type of thing if it
sounds like something that's that would
be cool then you would probably like it
because the acting is really excellent
you know like I said it looks nice even
though it's all like just in one area
yeah I do have to give it that the
acting was very good yeah um I really
couldn't keep track of the story too
much cuz I didn't really care well there
was a lot of tends along and he gets the
point oh my god [ __ ] it this is just
gonna be in this room I don't care you
know I mean so I check out a [ __ ] like
that pretty early yeah but other people
get drawn into it
yeah and I yeah I definitely was because
I got like really interested in what was
going on and like what everybody what
this person was going on cuz all because
everybody had like [ __ ] that was going
on behind the scenes that kind of came
out later on that was like related to
these two people dying
it was competently shot yeah and you
know sound was good you know production
was good everybody looked great you
nerdz good acting in it it's just the
format of the movies just wasn't for me
yeah yeah and like I said that's gonna
be completely up to the individual but
if it sounds like something you would
dig like I said it's on shudder they
just put it up there like a week or two
ago so if you want to check it out then
go on shudder and check it out
you